this altitude this episode is brought to
you by helix sleep I recently moved into
a new home and when I needed beds where
did I go I went to helix and I paid for
them with my own monies I tried all
sorts of mattresses some of you saw me
soliciting feedback and ideas on social
media I tested a ton and I ended up on
helix they offer mattresses personalize
to your preferences and sleeping style
without costing thousands of dollars
check it out let's sleep calm
forward-slash Tim and you can take there
very simple two to three minutes sleep
quiz to get started that's a diagnostic
and they can build your mattress from
there and ensure that it is something
you will absolutely love the quiz helps
determine the type of mattress that is
best for you by asking all sorts of
questions about your sleep behavior such
as if you tend to line your back side or
stomach as well as your body type for
couples they can even personalize each
side of the mattress their customer
service is phenomenal my assistant my
researcher I had them all test helix and
the customer service is really
outstanding the mattress arrives within
a week and the shipping is completely
free you can try the mattress then for a
hundred nights and if you're not happy
they'll pick it up and offer a full
refund
so check it out to personalize your
sleep experience visit helix sleep calm
forward-slash Tim and you can get $50
off of your custom mattress so check it
out helix sleep comm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by Legal
Zoom I've used Legal Zoom for many of my
businesses in Matt Mullenweg as one
example he's been on the podcast CEO of
automatic now worth more than a billion
dollars first incorporated his company
we're on Legal Zoom when you run your
own business you know that time equals
money so why waste your valuable time
dealing with issues that LegalZoom can
solve for you more than 2 million people
have used Legal Zoom to start their
businesses but their services don't end
at the beginning Legal Zoom has a
network of independent attorneys
licensed in all 50 states they can
provide all the advice you need nuts and
bolts start to finish and you don't need
to worry about billable hours because
Legal Zoom isn't a law firm that way you
have upfront pricing and complete
clarity Legal Zoom is a reliable
resource that more than a million people
have already trusted to help them with
their businesses in all sorts of
different ways and that includes setting
up wills doing a proper trademark search
for me an LLC setting up a non-profit or
finding simple cease and desist letter
templates so check them out
legalzoom.com take a look today to see
how they can make your life better
easier faster and more effective enter
promo code tim t IM at checkout to save
fifteen percent that's legalzoom.com
and code tim for fifteen percent off
good evening this is Jocko will Inc and
I am standing in as the host for the Tim
Ferriss show and I'm doing some talking
because right now mr. Tim Ferriss can't
talk to you himself because he is in a a
silent retreat where he's remaining in
complete silence for I think ten days
and it's not just silence it's actually
also no books no computers no phones
obviously it's just pure silence alone
with your thoughts not exactly what I
would want to do but it sounds kind of
crazy and it sounds like something Tim
Ferriss what do but in the meantime like
I said I am here to guest host this show
which is awesome
I appreciate that opportunity and thanks
to Tim Ferriss for giving me that
opportunity now a little bit about my
background first if you want to know
about me one of the best places to find
out about me is actually on this podcast
as well
Tim Ferriss episode number 107 and that
was released in September of 2015 and
that was the first time I was ever
interviewed really for anything and I
had been in the SEAL Teams for 20 years
I'd never done any interview I never had
any social media didn't have a website I
really didn't exist in the public eye at
all and so my background is that I grew
up in a small New England town I
enlisted in the Navy after high school I
went through boot camp I went to SEAL
training I spent some time at SEAL team
one in the 90s and eventually got picked
up for a commissioning program which
meant I was gonna become an officer in
the SEAL Teams and move into a
leadership position and eventually once
I did that the war started in September
September 11th 2001 and from there I
deployed to Iraq as a seal
soon commander and then as a seal task
unit commander when I was a tasking a
commander I fought in the Battle of
Ramadi Ramadi Iraq the capital valemar
province and very tough fighting in
incredible effort by the soldiers and
Marines on the ground and also the guys
that were with me as well from my SEAL
task unit and ended up being the most
highly decorated special operations unit
from the Iraq war and incredible
sacrifices were made for that victory
and when I got back from that deployment
to Iraq I took over the training for the
West Coast SEAL Teams and the training
that I took over isn't the training
where you've got the boat on your head
or you're carrying the logs around or
you're doing a bunch of push-ups and
pull-ups and runs and swims it's the the
real training where seals actually learn
to be seals to shoot move and
communicate to fire maneuver to close
with and destroy the enemy and they
learn about combat leadership and I did
that for my last few years and the SEAL
Teams taught that and then I retired in
2010 and when I did that I started
working with companies with businesses
in helping out with their leadership and
their management and that developed into
a leadership and management consulting
company which is called a salon front
that I run with my buddy and former
teammate Lafe babban who was one of the
platoon commanders that worked for me in
the Battle of Ramadi and we wrote a book
together which was called extreme
ownership and that is how I ended up
being on Tim's podcast for the first
time we had some mutual friends
Kirk parsley and dr. Peter Atia and they
made the intro and that's how I ended up
on this podcast the first time in that
book extreme ownership is a book about
leadership really it's combat leadership
lessons learned and tested on the
battlefield that that we then taught to
the next generation of seals and now
we're out there teaching these
leadership principles to businesses
and teams and organizations throughout
the civilian world and also in law
enforcement in fire departments in any
type of organization so that's what
we're doing now and as that book was
launching like I said I went on Tim's
podcast it was awesome and when we got
done with that podcast when Tim pressed
stop on the recorder he said you should
really have your own podcast and I kind
of you know I listened to him but I had
a bunch of stuff going on the book was
coming out and whatnot and then Jill
Rogan heard that podcast and asked me to
come on his podcast and in the middle of
that podcast Joe Rogan said you should
have your own podcast so I guess when
Tim Ferriss and Jill Rogan tell you you
should have your own podcast then you
should listen and I did and so I started
my own podcast which is called jockle
podcast and really it's a podcast about
human nature and and it's human nature
as viewed through the lens of war and
other human struggles and has definitely
focused on leadership but it also often
reveals the dark side of mankind and the
podcast can get pretty heavy and pretty
dark but it's not all like that and I
also know as we did the podcast as I
continued to putting it out there I also
talked about all kinds of other things
about life and and how I live about
surfing and about jiu-jitsu and about
working out and about eating and how I
eat and sleeping and how I sleep and how
to wake up earlier and how to overcome
procrastination and how to accomplish
goals and how to get the most out of
life and all those kind of things
your basic winning and in there I I
wrote a book for kids and a book that
wrote for kids is called way of the
warrior kid and it's you know it's about
a kid that's having a tough time at
school he didn't know how to couldn't do
any pull-ups and he didn't those times
tables so he kind of felt stupid and he
didn't know how to swim because he was
afraid of the water and he was getting
picked on at school and the last day of
school everything kind of comes
brushing down on him and he goes home
all sad but when he gets home he
remembers that his uncle is coming to
stay with him for the summer and his
uncle was a seal in the SEAL Teams and
so his uncle finds out what these
problems are that the kid is suffering
through and says look oh you can't you
can't swim you don't know how to do any
pull-ups or you can't do any pull-ups
you don't know your time stablest you're
getting picked on at school we can
handle those problems so they go on a
little journey and the uncle uncle Jake
teaches young mark how to overcome all
these challenges and so that book came
out and but people were asking for sort
of details on the aspect of my life
about you know not about the leadership
stuff but about my sort of kind of
operating system and so eventually I put
that down kind of my mode of living into
the way I live and this book is called
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
and it just came out October 17th and
that's how I ended up doing this podcast
for Tim because like I said Tim is I
guess fortunately or unfortunately
depending on how you're looking at it
tim is is not allowed to talk right now
and so he but he had read the book just
before he went into his period of
silence and he wanted me to come on
while he was not able to speak and talk
about some of the high points that might
be that he thought would be a useful
introduction to people that listened to
his podcast so that's why I'm here if
you're expecting Tim I apologize I know
that's always a bummer when you're
expecting to have that person that you
you know and you're you're anticipating
hearing their voice and then it turns
out not to be that person so if you've
made it this far thank you and here we
go the book is broken in two sections
the sections Oh first section is called
thoughts and the second section is
called actions and the thoughts section
is about
well basically it's what goes through my
head its how I view and how I think
about things and Tim wanted me to focus
on the actions part but for one example
of what is in the thoughts category I'm
going to the book here this is directly
from the book discipline equals freedom
Field Manual here we go people want to
know how to stop laziness they want to
know how to stop procrastination they
have an idea in their head maybe even a
vision but they don't know where to
start so they ask and they say where do
I start when is the best time to start
and I have a simple answer here and now
that's it you want to improve you want
to get better you want to get on a
workout program or a clean diet or start
a new business you want to write a book
or make a movie or build a house or a
computer or an app where do you start
you start right here when do you start
you start right now you initiate action
you go here is the reality that idea
isn't going to execute itself that book
isn't going to write itself
those waits out in the gym they aren't
going to move themselves you have to do
it and you have to do it now so stop
thinking about it stop dreaming about it
stop researching every aspect of it and
reading all about it and debating the
pros and cons of it start doing it take
that first step and make it happen get
after it
here and now
so that's the kind of things that are in
the book the first part of the book
which again is called thoughts and like
I said the second part is what I
actually do to implement those thoughts
into my life and of course Tim being mr.
pragmatic how do we get to it how do we
make it happen he asked me to detail
some of those for you and one of the
things that he wanted me to talk about
was early morning training and what role
getting up early because I get up early
in the morning what role that plays in
my life and why I kind of maintained
that and have maintained that for a long
time and there's one section that talks
about kind of a little psychological
edge that I believe the waking up early
in the morning gives anyone that wakes
up in the early in the morning so here's
a little chunk of the book where I talk
about that psychological edge there are
a slew of psychological advantages that
come from early morning physical
training first there is a psychological
win over the enemy knowing that you are
working harder than your adversaries
gives you an advantage it gives you
confidence that you can overcome them in
battle another advantage to waking up
early and working out hard is that it
demands discipline to do both now some
scientists have claimed that discipline
dissipates the more it is used that
willpower is a finite resource that is
reduced every time it is used throughout
the day this is wrong that does not
happen to the contrary I believe and
studies have shown that discipline and
willpower do not go down as they're
called into action they actually get
stronger this is obvious if you actually
try the experiment yourself before you
go to bed
what workout you're going to do in the
morning stage your workout clothes so
you don't even have to think about them
when you get up write down a list of
things you need to accomplish the next
day set your alarm clock for 4:30 a.m.
and go to sleep when the alarm clock
goes off get up
put on your pre-staged clothes brush
your teeth and go get your workout on
hard get done shower get dressed and
begin to crush the lists of tasks you
made for the day when it's time for
breakfast see what happens you won't
want to eat junk you won't want that
disgusting doughnut you'll want some
eggs and bacon and that will happen at
lunch too you're feeling good energized
you don't want to eat that worthless
calories of pizza or french fries you
want fuel good fuel to rebuild your body
clean fuel that keeps your mind sharp
when you're on the path you want to stay
on the path unfortunately the opposite
is also true
once you step off the path you tend to
stray far when you don't prepare what
you need to do the next day when you
sleep in and then skip your workout and
you don't start attacking the tasks you
have because you didn't write them down
the night before that is when you make
bad decisions that is when your will and
discipline fail you figure you might as
well have that doughnut have that
doughnut for breakfast and once you've
done that might as well put down four or
five pieces of pizza for lunch it
doesn't matter anymore you're off the
path and that is a disaster
you will didn't break it never showed up
in the first place so get on the path of
discipline and stay on the path
discipline begets disciplined will prop
gates more will hold the line across the
line and victory will be yours so that's
why I wake up early in the morning and
work out and also in the book I talk
about how you actually start getting up
early in the morning because this is a
big challenge for a lot of people I know
it I get it and there's a bunch of ways
to do this and one of the most important
things to allow you to get up early in
the morning is to go to bed earlier but
going to bed earlier is also a challenge
and again I talked about this in the
book but how do you how what's the most
important thing to to put into place to
go to bed earlier is number one you want
to be tired when you get to the end of
the day you want to be tired that's how
you get to go to bed earlier number two
turn off the internet because they've
got these little people that are
programming things into the interwebs
that are truly just meant to get you to
click one more time just click one more
time and watch one more one more video
one more stupid video that's not getting
you anything not improving you in any
way so turn off the internet and if you
need to do something then read a book
pick up a book and read a book and the
most important thing to allow you to go
to bed earlier the most important thing
you can do is actually get up earlier
right that's what happens you when you
get up earlier well then you're more
tired by the end of the day and then you
can go to sleep and that that gets you
in the right pattern
so the way you start getting the way you
start going to bed earlier is by getting
up earlier and again I detail this and
the way that pattern kind of unfolds
itself in the book
now another thing that Tim wanted me to
hit on was my actual workouts like what
my workouts look like from week to week
and I'll say this I have a bunch of a
bunch of kind of standard workouts that
I use and they may vary a little bit
depending on what I'm feeling like or
what is needed or maybe I got some
little injury that I have to cover up or
or maybe I'm really tired from some
other workout that I did so I need to
make an adjustment or maybe I haven't
worked out in a few days someone needed
to go even harder so there's little
adjustments that go by and and I
actually took a lot of these standard
workouts that I have and I put them in
the book again this is something that
people really wanted to hear from me
what my workouts actually were and so I
put them in there and and they go from
the beginner level from from people that
really haven't worked out before all the
way to intermediate all the way up to
advanced and and I've been able to I
actually own a gym in California a big
mixed martial arts gym but we've got all
kinds of you know we've got Olympic
lifting we've got we've got everything
in there and so I've seen people and
trained people at all levels from you
know total non athlete that haven't done
anything active in years all the way to
the highest level athletes that are
fighting professionally in the UFC so
I've seen and brought people through
those different those different
categories over over the past 10 years
that I've been training civilians so
that's that's what this book contains is
what those are like now I also go after
different goals because you want to be
chasing something at least I do I want
to be chasing something I want to be
trying to achieve something but I don't
just continually chase the same thing so
sometimes I'll be trying to me and maybe
I'll spend a month trying to increase my
deadlift and get my deadlift up up there
and then sometimes I'll be just trying
to run and get my my 3 mile timed run or
my 4 mile timed run down or
I'm trying to max out on pull-ups and
see how many pull-ups I can get and and
so I'm kind of always chasing some goal
of some kind and I never go too far in
one direction because I think that that
would not suit me for the way I live for
instance if I was just trying to get a
massive deadlift which is awesome but if
that's my sole purpose is to get a
massive deadlift well then I'm gonna be
as big and strong as possible but that's
obviously gonna hurt my mobility it's
gonna hurt Mike my cardio and so I get
to a point where you know I may be some
percentage of my percent of my
capability and then once I get to that
percentage and I get to that point where
I'm really gonna have to change my
lifestyle and quote in order to increase
beyond that that's when I say okay you
know what of this is where my deadlift
is that right now let's start looking at
how many pull-ups I can do or let's
let's start seeing one other exercise I
can move on to and find some other
challenge so that's sort of what my my
workouts are like I'm always chasing
something the other thing with this is
people get really fanatical about
working out in and they get into the
where their workout becomes a form of
religion and and that's one of the
reasons that I never really talk
specifically about what I do for my
workouts because don't really like to
preach about you know you should do this
or you should do that so I'm but people
are interested so that's that's why I
put it out there and it is you know the
the kind of training that I do it it
definitely has been effective for me
over the years and my various jobs so
but I'm not a person that says hey my
way is better than everyone else's way
I'm not one of those people I'm not
saying that at all actually there's
people that know more than me and
there's people that have the better
methodologies or different methodologies
that work well for their system and
that's cool that's cool if you if you
want to text or whatever hit put put on
social media 8,000 times that you have
something better that's awesome good I
appreciate your input but I've been
doing what I've
done for a long time and it's not a
religion to me it's just a cool way of
working out so my workouts are are kind
of split into some broad movements the
broad movement movements are pull push
lift and squat and how those breakout
pull is basically centered around
pull-ups and in seal training you do a
lot of pull-ups and pulps are obviously
important because you got to be able to
pull yourself up climb ladders all those
things and so and it's also good to know
that you can move your body weight
around
so pull-ups are a huge part of my
workouts and and pull-ups is what the
pull day is centered on I'm gonna do all
different kinds of pull-ups close grip
and narrow grip and wide grip and ring
pull ups and and climbing ropes and and
obviously pull-ups on the pull-up bar
and so that's what the pull day is is
based on the push day is again it goes
back it's rooted in seal training which
is the push day is basically centered
around push-ups and dips and so again
all the different kinds of push-ups and
all the different kinds of dips ring
dips bar dips push-ups Close Grip
push-ups a wide grip push-ups dive
bomber push-ups all these different
types of push-ups that you can do that's
what that push day is centered on the
lift day is for lack of a better way to
explain this the lift day for me is
primarily about getting things off the
ground and over my head so so that means
deadlifts it means cleans it means clean
and jerk it means press it means
snatches it means handstand push-ups
those kind of exercises that's what the
lift day is to me and then finally squat
which could also be called leg day but
that obviously focuses on all different
kinds of squatting from back squat and
front squat and overhead squat and all
the other types of variations of squats
that there are but also it's not just
squatting because I'll do plyometrics
and sprinting and calisthenics that are
Legg focused so those are the kind of
four categories pull push lift and squat
and then on top of those I do gut which
I guess it's what normal people kind of
call core or abs but I just have always
called a gut again that's rooted in the
SEAL Teams they would when I was a new
guy in 1990 whatever they'd say we're
gonna do some gut work and what that
meant was you were gonna work out your
abs you're gonna do sit-ups you're gonna
do Russian twist you're gonna do all
flutter kicks all those things and and
then on top of that I do metabolic
conditioning and and the way I do
metabolic conditioning which is
basically that means you're gonna be
breathing hard really hard for either a
short intense amount of time or maybe a
little bit longer but that's that's what
I definitely do metabolic conditioning
and the reason I do metabolic
conditioning is so that I'm in good
shape so I can sustain a high output for
short bursts and multiple short bursts
and over longer periods of time and I
mix that in sometimes with the workout
itself and sometimes I do it before the
workout sometimes I do it after the
workout and I mean if you if you talk
about what my workouts consist of as far
as time goes my workouts just depend on
what's going on in my world in that day
some of my workouts are very quick and I
can get them done in less than ten
minutes and they make you want to throw
up and at the same time some of them
sometimes I'm working out for three
hours you know maybe doing singles and
doubles and triples on on weights for
heavy exercises so and it depends it
depends what I'm doing what my current
goal is how I set those up and it also
depends on what life is throwing at me
obviously I out on the road somewhere
you can't always do heavy squats because
you're hotel gym only has to thirty five
pound dumbbells which really puts the
heavy squats out of the picture so you
got to be able to
depth and make something else happen so
Tim asked that I talk about what an
actual series of workouts from me would
look like and so like I said in the book
I actually put the workouts in the book
and so I'll kind of read through some of
these workouts a few days so you get the
feel for what it is and these are I went
right to the advanced workouts again
there's beginner intermediate advanced
maybe I'll talk a little bit about some
of the beginner ones too but there is a
place to start if you can't do anything
you can still get started
but the advanced here's it here's an
example of what I would do on a pole day
for for an advanced workout so here we
go
the primary work is gonna be 30 muscle
ups and a muscle up is on rings you can
do them on a bar - I do them usually on
rings a muscle up is where you hold on
to rings or a bar like we'd like you're
gonna do pull up you do a pull up but
you pull yourself all the way up and
then press through until you've done a
dip and now you're in the dip position
either on top of the bar or on above the
Rings so it's called a muscle up if you
can't understand my description then you
can go to youtube and look up muscle up
and you'll see them so 30 muscle ups and
then a hundred dead hang pull ups and
then a hundred kipping pull-ups and I'll
do all those for time as fast as I can
and then when I get done with those I'll
do some hang cleans which again this is
a place where you want might want to go
to youtube and check out what a hang
clean is YouTube is a incredible
instrument and tool for for trying to
learn that being said when you go and
you look at the YouTube video what you
think you're doing is not what you
probably are doing and that's why
getting a coach to help you is very
important I remember one time I was
coaching a guy in boxing and in boxing
you you're supposed to move your head
from side to side there's certain
movements that your head is supposed to
have and I was I was watching him do it
and he
you know how's my head movement looking
I hadn't trained him in a while he said
he said how's my head movement looking
at him looking and I said won't go ahead
and and let me see it and so he started
doing in his it was hilarious because
his head was staying absolutely still
but his shoulders would he would lift
his left shoulder than lift his right
shoulder than lift his left shoulder
than lift his right children but his
head was staying still and I said okay
it's okay just come here and look in the
mirror cuz when when you shadowbox you
use a mirror and he looked in the mirror
and he saw what was happening and in his
mind his head was moving back and forth
from left to right but in reality the
only thing that was moving was his
shoulders lifting up so you have to be
very careful when you're when you're
lifting weights that you you you truly
are doing what you think you're doing
and the easiest way to do that is to
have a coach come and watch you do your
movements so for instance the Hank lean
is a ISM is a movement that I would do
next in this workout and I would just do
probably six sets six sets of between
three to six repetitions and again I'm
just trying to maintain good form and
then get done without so I've done 30
muscle ups I've done a hundred dead hang
pull ups and a dead hang pull up if you
don't know what that is that's where you
you don't use any motion of your body
you're using pure strength and then I do
100 kipping pulps oh and before everyone
thinks I'm lying or or whatever I can't
do a hundred dead hang pull ups in a row
I can't do thirty muscle ups in a row I
can't do 100 kipping pull-ups in a row I
I'm what I'm going to talk about doing
these I talk about doing as many as I
can and then I have to stop and shake it
out and then I jump up and do some more
so maybe for my hundred dead hang pull
ups maybe my first set I only get 14
dead hang pull ups I drop off the bar I
shake it out I jump up there and I do
another 10 so now I'm at 24 and then I
can't do any more so I drop off the bar
maybe I get another set of 10 then I'm
at 34 and so that's what I'm gonna do
until I get to 100 when I get to 100
dead hang pull ups now it's time for me
to do kipping pulps and I'll do the same
thing maybe the first set I do 40
kipping pull-ups once I've done 40 I
shake off the bar I drop off the bar
shake it out a little bit I'll jump up
back on the bar now
20 so him up to 60 and now I drop off
the bar I do it again I go to 80 so so
that's what I'm talking about you're
gonna break up these sets until you can
get the number that you're aiming for
so then after I've done 30 muscle ups
100 dead hang pull ups 100 kipping
pull-ups and then I jump into doing some
six sets of hang cleans with a weight
that allows you to do three to six
repetitions per set while you're still
maintaining good four minutes again it's
protocol to maintain good forms and then
I would do five sets of reverse curls
followed by regular curls now I used to
I went through the stage of saying all
curls you know those are those just the
exercise for looking good and I was kind
of derogatory on doing curls but I
changed my mind I would say a few years
ago I changed my mind because well I
hurt my bicep and when I hurt my bicep I
said to myself well maybe my bicep isn't
as strong as it should be and the
tendons going into it maybe aren't as
strong as they should be and so maybe I
should do Sal ittle bit of isolation
training on those muscles to make them
stronger and so that's what I started
doing and it's it's worked out well my
my bicep healed and it hasn't been
injured since then so so that's an
exercise that even though people might
think Oh curls that's a bodybuilding
exercise why would I do that I don't
care about looking good I just want to
be strong well it makes you stronger too
so that's that's the curls then from
there I would do some gut work the the
gut work I have listed on this
particular work up is a hundred v-ups
which is when you're laying flat on your
back arms extended above your head feet
extended as far as you can and then you
close up like a jackknife in a V
position until you touch your toes to
your fingers and then you lay back down
do a hundred of those and then a hundred
Russian twists which is when your feet
are up in the air your your torso is up
in the air and you're bringing your
hands back and forth from side to side
get done without and then I would do a
little net
work so metabolic conditioning and for
this one here I have listed do four sets
of cleans and pull-ups with the
following repetition so I'd do a set of
20 cleans followed by 20 pull-ups then
15 cleans followed by 15 pulps than 10
cleans followed by 10 pull-ups than 5
cleans followed by 5 bulbs and that's
what I would do and for the cleans I'd
use probably about 60% of my body weight
to do cleans and there you get a little
get a little cardio work during that you
will be breathing hard I promise if you
give that a shot so there's an example
of a workout that I would do and for my
pull day you know I'll talk about four
let's just do one more go go for a push
day push day here's another workout so
for this push day I would be doing 3
minutes on and 1 minute rest of the
following exercises ring dips which are
dips using gymnastics rings ring
push-ups dips clap push-ups deep push-up
so I do those deep push-ups in in
parallettes which are something or use
something where you can go deeper than
your normal range of motion if you're on
the floor and then just regular push-ups
on the floor and so I'd set my timer for
three minutes of work and followed by a
1 minute of rest and then I'd go through
the ring dips
as many as I can in 3 minutes then rest
a minute and then do the same thing for
the ring push-ups the dips the clap
push-ups the deep push-ups and then
regular push-ups and once my time is up
and this is something I always do is
that when I get to that last set the
last set is kind of the easiest exercise
so regular push-ups are easier than clap
push-ups and they're easier than deep
push-ups when I get there I'm always
gonna do 100 at that last that last set
so then again that doesn't mean I can do
100 pushups in a row especially after
I've done all this other work but I will
continue to take rests and break up the
set until I can get to what I want to do
let's say I get to that number of 100
now I get done without and I would do
some repetitions of the snatch movement
the snatch is a really hard movement to
do and again YouTube has some good
visuals of what it looks like to do is
snatch but if you're gonna start
snatching you really need to get someone
to watch you and a good qualified coach
that can that could watch you and make
sure that you're doing these exercises
right and you know I would do some
repetitions of that just to keep just to
build my own muscle memory and try and
get better at the exercise I'm not great
at that exercise and then do some gut
hold a plank for five minutes and then
for the metcon for the metabolic
conditioning I'd do three rounds of max
burpees in three minutes with one minute
of rest between the rounds and that
right there
that'll inflict some damage on you if
you go hard you're actually two minutes
of burpees can crush people if you go as
hard as you possibly can for two minutes
of burpees it can it can leave my or can
leave a mark I will tell you now for the
lifting again you've got to be really
careful and make sure that your your
technique is absolutely critical and you
got them if you sacrifice your form you
will it will not make you stronger it
will actually make you injured and I
wrote that in the book that right there
sacrificing proper form will not make
you stronger it will only make you
injured so try and find a good coach
that's gonna teach you these things and
for this for instance on a lift day in
this in this workout that I've got in
the book it's you can I do eight to ten
sets of clean and jerks building up to
four sets that when the weight that
allows me to do two to four repetitions
so I'm just doing eight to ten sets
taking some time in between you said
this is a day where I'm trying to get
stronger trying to build my strength
trying to build my clean-and-jerk so
it's pretty simple it's pretty
straightforward eight to ten sets of
clean and jerks
and I'm doing I'm trying to build up to
where I do four of the sets are with a
pretty heavy weight that I can only do
two three maybe four times get done with
that I'm gonna do some hanging
windshield wipers from my
which is when you hang from a bar and
you bring your legs back and forth like
a set of windshield wipers they're
brutal by the way so we be be ready for
that
sounds all sounds all easy they're not
and then for the metcon I would do this
here about 60% of body weight 30
repetitions of clean and jerks without
putting the bar down once you get done
with that rest 2 minutes do 20
repetitions of clean and jerks with the
same way get done with that rest 2
minutes all those without putting the
bar down then the last one you perform
10 repetitions so you do you get about
60 percent of your body weight you do 30
reps don't put the bar down during the
30 reps once you're done with the third
reps you can put the bar down rest for 2
minutes then take up the bar again do 20
reps same weight when you're done with
that put the bar down rest for 2 minutes
2 minutes is up
do it again 10 repetitions and then
you're done that's gonna get you
something
it's a tough workout I can assure you
and lastly for for a squat day what I
would do here is just gonna do some some
some squats I would do 50 overhead
squats with about 60% body weight and
again this is something gonna break up
you're gonna do what you can you get
done with 50 reps of that you're gonna
do 50 front squats with about 80% of
your body weight and then 50 back squats
with your body weight that's it pretty
simple get done with that do some gut
100 sit-ups with 20 percent of your body
weight sitting on your chest and the
metcon is to run 2 miles and I usually
like to do some kind of a run when I get
done squatting because it kind of
loosens up the legs and get some of that
lactic acid moved out of there so those
are some examples of the workouts that I
do and then I would I normally just go
right back into the workout however
sometimes after I'm brutalized myself
for multiple days in a row I feel like
and so I might take a rest day and what
I do in a rest day is I'll still do
something maybe we'll just go for a jog
maybe I'll go for a swim
maybe let's go in there and do some some
burpees to warm up and then just do some
good stretching but I don't like to take
a lot of days off scheduled days off
because I think life brings me days off
when the more often than I need so
whether it's you're traveling or whether
it's your water heater breaks or your
car broke down or your kid got sick and
you have to miss your workout that's
when I take my days off when I'm forced
to by life now again inside this book
I've got beginner routines as well and
the beginner routines are actually I'll
look at one right now for instance and
for a pull-up workout all you're gonna
do is eight sets of max pull-ups so you
might only be able to do three pull-ups
and guess what you're gonna do three
pull-ups in and then you'll rest for a
few minutes then you'll do another three
or maybe you're only doing two and then
you do that eight times and if you can't
do any pull-ups at all there's an answer
to that as well you jump up on the bar
and you hold yourself up there as long
as you can and you just do the negative
work so and and then you get done with
that you do some sit-ups as many as you
can in two minutes and then run 400
meters two times that's that's a
beginner workout out inside this book so
I started off pretty easy and then it
escalates as you get in better shape and
by the way you can do that workout right
there it's a beginner workout but you
can do it if you do it if you're
advanced and you do it you'll still
crush yourself because instead of doing
three pull-ups your first set you'll be
doing 58 and then you'll get me you'll
be getting your workout on so again
that's that's the way the the workout
book are though the book is set up as
far as workouts goes I also talked a
little bit about training on the road
because I spend a lot of time traveling
with ashlyn from our consulting company
so I'm in hotel rooms a lot and I got
some stuff in there about the kind of
workouts that I do in hotel gyms you
know sometimes I'll for instance throw a
towel over a piece of gym equipment if
they don't have a pull-up bar or I'll go
into a parking garage because just about
every parking garage
has some kind of plumbing or piping up
in the ceiling and so you can find a
place that you can jump up and you can
do some pull-ups be careful don't don't
break the plumbing and cause massive
amounts of damage but you find a good
pipe or you find a an i-beam that you
can get you can get ahold of and you go
there and you do some pull-ups so
there's that I've done I've spend many
times doing dips between treadmills I
don't really like treadmills if I'm
gonna run them and go run but the the
treadmills have big handles on them so
I'll kind of move those around the floor
a little bit and get some dips on those
and sometimes in fact oftentimes it's
just the hotel room floor with their
nasty carpets and on those nasty carpets
I'll do burpees I'll do push-ups I'll do
gut exercises handstand push-ups squats
pistols which are one-legged squats I'll
do whatever and I'll just get crazy with
the calisthenics and a lot of times also
when I'm in the road is I don't have a
lot of time because I'm meeting with a
client and I'm speaking and then I'm
going to a meeting and so my my workout
and I flew in and I got in late and so a
lot of times I'll just be doing some
kind of a quick workout to maintain the
discipline the to maintain the
discipline and to get some level of
workout and to get the blood flowing
because I think it's bad when you don't
wake up and do something I always feel
groggy for the day so one of my favorite
quick workouts to do is is a hundred
burpees for time one minute rest 100
burpees for time get some of that again
it should probably take you less than
less than 20 minutes for sure and once
you get done with that you'll you'll
have the blood flowing and you'll feel
better about yourself again all those
are in the book and yeah you can check
them out now another section of the book
that Tim wanted me to talk about was I
talked about martial arts in the book
and I've been training martial arts for
a long time and there's various types of
martial arts there's striking there's
grappling and there's weapons these are
the kind of broad the broad martial arts
categories right striking which is when
you're hitting
people grappling which is when you're
grabbing people and using weapons
obviously there's all kinds of different
weapons from knives to swords to sticks
to firearms guns and so I talked about
those things but I talked a lot about
jujitsu which which i think is the best
base to have for martial arts and Tim
liked this part where I talked about why
to start with Brazilian jiu-jitsu and
how it should be taught for self-defense
so here we're going to the book where I
talk about why to start with Brazilian
jiu-jitsu start with Brazilian jiu-jitsu
it is a form of grappling that is highly
advanced because for the most part the
actual fighting takes place on the
ground this is a key point because our
first form of self-defense is to get
away yes to run if you are confronted by
another person or a group of people the
best thing you can do is run away avoid
the conflict this is relatively easy if
someone is trying to strike you with
punches or kicks they do not have
control over you so you can simply run
away from them you have won the problem
comes in a self-defense situation when
someone is grabbing you now they are
preventing your first line of
self-defense running away as soon as
someone grabs you you are in a grappling
scenario and one of the most critical
parts of Brazilian jiu-jitsu is escaping
from someone's grip so you can run
oftentimes an attacker will take you to
the ground in order to prevent you from
escaping their grip when this happens
the ability to ground fight isn't used
not to stay on the ground but to get up
and get away from the attacker the first
goal of a beginner in jiu-jitsu is not
to get the fight to the ground but to
get up off the ground and get away this
is an important distinction from people
who believe the goal of self-defense in
jiu-jitsu is to get
the attacker to the ground this is not
true the goal is to get away but as has
been seen over and over again
fights often end up on the ground and
therefore a person must be prepared for
it not training in jiu-jitsu because you
don't want to go to the ground is like
not learning how to swim because you
don't want to go in the water
it doesn't make sense the safest way to
deal with the water is to be comfortable
in it just as being comfortable on the
ground is the best way to deal with that
scenario should it unfold in real life
so that's one of those things that
people understandably so if they learn
that if they think that jiu-jitsu if you
get attacked what you're gonna do is
grab someone and pull them to the ground
that's that's not what the goal is the
goal is to get away from people so
unfortunately in many fights they end up
on the ground because if you start
hitting someone their defense might be
to grab you and when they grab you now
you're in a grappling scenario so that
is why Jitsu is very important now
there's other great martial arts and I
talked about them in the book as well
one of the things that Tim asked me
about is if I was teaching a jujitsu to
a sort of a semi athletic person not not
not an Olympic decathlete but not a
couch potato either what would the first
week look like and the first the first
week would be pretty straightforward
the things I would want someone to
understand are the fundamental positions
of jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu is a grappling
art you're you're wrestling with another
human being and there's certain
positions and they have certain
advantages and disadvantages and so I
would want them to understand these
fundamental positions one's called the
mount one's called the guard one's
called the back one's called side
control one is called half guard and I
would want people to understand what
those positions were and how they
related to jiu-jitsu and the next thing
I would understand is this position I
would want my student
this position called the mouth the
position is a position of dominance in
jujitsu the person that is mounted is on
the top position and they have a lot of
control over the person that's beneath
them and you if you are trapped there
you're in a lot of trouble and so one of
the first things I would teach people is
how to escape from that mounted position
when you're on the bottom and how to get
back up to their feet that's the next
thing is how do you get back up to your
feet effectively so that you can get
away and then I would want them to learn
if they are if they are in the mounted
position how would they do some kind of
a submission hold that's one of the best
things about jujitsu is there's
something called submission holds in it
where you can make the person tap out or
you can break their arm or put them to
sleep through a chokehold so I'd want
them to start to learn to understand
what submissions they are threatened
with in the mountain that means you need
to know what the offense is and then I
would want them to understand how this
other position which is called the guard
and the guard is where you're on the
bottom position so someone has taken you
to the ground and you're on the bottom
and they're on top of you with their
weight but you've managed to get your
legs around their body so you have some
control over their body weight and then
once I they understand how important
that position is then I would say teach
them some submissions and some sweeps
which is when you change position you
you put the person on you put your
opponent on the bottom you were on the
bottom and then you you sweep them and
you put them on the bottom and the whole
time that I'm teaching these things I
think it's very important in jiu-jitsu
that you actually spar with other people
because people need to believe that
jujitsu works and one of the best ways
to convince people that jujitsu works is
to actually have them participate in it
then actually have them train against
another person that's good because when
you train with someone that's good
that's 40 pounds lighter than you and
clearly weaker than you are and yet they
can tap you out over and over and over
again it is a real eye opener and it
will make a believer out of just
about anyone so it's good to roll now
you do have to be careful because when
people first start they go crazy their
ego gets out of control and everyone
wants to just go a thousand percent
against their opponent so it's usually
better to pair up someone against
someone that's a little bit better than
them or maybe even quite a bit better
than them so they can understand how
effective it is and they can understand
that no matter how much they panic or no
match no matter how much they thrash
around no matter how much they use all
their strength that doesn't work in
comparison to good jujitsu technique so
that's what it is for me how I would
kind of that's how I actually I do start
people in jiu-jitsu now there's
something else to be said when you go to
a school the school whenever you go does
not revolve around you just showing up
there so you you may not get this basic
information but what's cool about
jiu-jitsu is I look at it sort of like
learning a language and one of the best
ways to learn languages through
immersion training and that's what's
gonna happen you show but many jiu-jitsu
schools you are going to get immersed in
something you don't know what anything
means just like if you showed up in a
foreign country with a foreign language
you wouldn't understand anything at
first and then you start to recognize a
word here and a word there and then you
recognize a little sentence fragment and
then eventually you start putting the
pieces together and then you can speak
the language the same thing happens in
jiu-jitsu so you start recognizing to
move and you see were another move ties
into it and eventually put together a
fragment of a series of moves and then
eventually you learn the language of
jujitsu so it's good to get the basics
of of all the different positions and
there's a million places to see those
online so that you'd kind of understand
fundamentally what's happening in
jiu-jitsu but the immersion training is
very important as well and you get in
there you get in them on the mat and you
start training now people also always
ask where should I train what's a good
school and there's I talked about this
in the book and I'll go over some of the
highlights of where how to find a good
jiu-jitsu school again I get asked this
all the time and there's luckily in
America there's so many really good
jiu-jitsu schools now it is jiu-jitsu is
very popular
in America when I started there was very
few schools in all of America and I was
lucky to have a good school in San Diego
California but that has spread now and
there's really good schools all over the
place so number one thing I look at is
actually proximity from a home or work I
think it's very important that wherever
you're gonna train is close enough to
you that you can get there conveniently
without an 87 minute transit to get
there know if I've got a place that's I
want my place to be as close as I can I
think that's one of the primary things
you look at how close is it so it's easy
to get to whether you go there after
work and it's so it's close to work or
whether you go there after when when you
get home because it's close to home
either way but having to drive 97
minutes to get to train somewhere is not
going to be beneficial for your training
so look for someone somewhere close the
other thing is now you need to find a
qualified instructor there's a lot of
qualified instructors out there there's
and you might have a black belt and
there's a lot of outstanding black belts
but you might only have a brown belt or
a purple belt depending on where you are
in the world and how much jiu-jitsu is
where you are and so you might only have
a purple or a brown belt and that's
actually fine and back in the back in
the 90s there were many schools in
America that were run by purple belts
and they were very successful and taught
a lot of great guys and now there's more
black belts so that's more common as far
as the legitimacy of the instructor you
can really there's a lot of really good
internet police out there that keep thee
the fakers in check so a quick google
maybe ask some people check some forums
and find out if the person is legit or
not and that's that's very beneficial
because you definitely want a good
qualified instructor now the other thing
is with schools is there's two different
extremes on the schools there's very
traditional schools and there's very
non-traditional schools the traditional
schools are everyone's wearing the same
uniform everything is done the same
structured way each class the
instructors are called sensei or master
or professor and and that's one type of
school and they're great some schools
that are set up like that are great
schools there's also very
non-traditional schools that are very
loose and everyone's wearing a different
kind of uniform and people are kind of
coming on and off the mat and instead of
calling the instructor professor or
master or sensei they'll just call them
Jocko or Dean or Jeff you know just it's
all good we're all friends and we're
training hard and there's no formalities
there's no bowing there's all kinds of
different schools and and again both
those types of schools are good and then
both those types of schools have
absolutely produced world champions now
but it kind of depends what you like
what type of personality you have and
where you think you'll fit in and by the
way there's there schools everywhere in
between as well there's schools that are
kind of in the gray area between the the
very loose school - the very traditional
school there's some schools that are in
the middle and then you want to check
that atmosphere out you know what is
that atmosphere like and does the
atmosphere match the goals that you have
as a person you know if you just want to
learn some jiu-jitsu and start to train
and you don't want to compete but you
want to know some good self-defense
yeah that's a one type of school and you
can find a school with that attitude you
can also find schools that are crazy
competitive and that's all they're
focused on it's sport jiu-jitsu and how
can I win the next tournament and
they'll have very intense training so
and and again everything in between so
you want to find a place that goes and
matches your goals and and I would
recommend when you go into a gym you try
some classes you see what they're like
you meet the other students you ask the
other students what their goals are in
jiu-jitsu and I think you would you you
can make a good decision and another
thing is I always say this jiu-jitsu is
jiu-jitsu is not a religion it's and
your instructors are not gods there are
people that are good at jiu-jitsu so if
you start feeling there's a cult
scenario happening just be careful that
you shouldn't feel like that jiu-jitsu
[ __ ] is fun
and it's a great sport so you shouldn't
be feeling that cold
scenario happening and you shouldn't be
looking at your jujitsu instructor as a
religious deity so that's how you pick a
school and and the book also discusses
other martial arts boxing wrestling Muay
Thai and like I said firearms training
and and what's interesting about all
these different types of training and
you might be thinking that I don't I'm
not interested in martial arts which is
fine but I will tell you that first of
all martial arts are great to train not
only are they great for self-defense and
you learn how to handle yourself they
actually also make you a better person
in a lot of different ways you're able
to handle yourself in any toughest
situation you get confident because you
know you can take care of yourself and
just the physical training may make you
sharper both mentally and physically
sharper and and tougher and so that's
that's why I think training martial arts
and jujitsu and boxing and Muay Thai and
wrestling and in firearms training and
all these different martial arts type
training they they will help you not
just in those specific arenas but in
everything that you're doing in your
life and I think that's I think that's
really why a lot of people listen to Tim
you know myself included just we all
want to hear ways to get better in every
different aspect of life and the one
thing that I know will make you better
is discipline the discipline to get up
the discipline to workout every day the
discipline to eat right in the
discipline to make good financial
decisions and make discipline choices
about how you spend your time doing
productive things I think that
discipline is the true pathway to
improvement and like the book says
discipline is ultimately the pathway to
freedom so a bunch of stuff in the book
I appreciate everyone listening I
supremely appreciate Tim for inviting me
on to do this show while
he's not allowed to talk I still AM I
appreciate that and appreciate
everything that Tim does and has done to
support me and what I'm doing and for
continuing to put out all the great
content that he puts out to the world to
help everyone out there learn implement
and improve that's all I got
appreciate everyone listening have a
good one y'all out hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday and
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour workweek com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by helix
sleep I recently moved into a new home
and when I needed beds where did I go I
went to see flips and I paid for them
with my own monies I tried all sorts of
mattresses some of you saw me soliciting
feedback and ideas on social media I
tested a ton and I ended up on helix
they offer mattresses personalized to
your preferences and sleeping style
without costing thousands of dollars so
check it out
blitz sleep comm forward slash Tim and
you can take there very simple two to
three minutes sleep quiz to get started
but the diagnostic and they can build
your mattress from there and ensure that
it is something
we'll absolutely love the quiz helps
determine the type of mattress that is
best for you by asking all sorts of
questions about your sleep behavior such
as if you tend to lie on your back side
or stomach as well as your body type for
couples they can even personalize each
side of the mattress their customer
service is phenomenal my assistant my
researcher I had them all test helix and
the customer service is really
outstanding the mattress arrives within
a week and the shipping is completely
free you can try the mattress then for a
hundred nights and if you're not happy
they'll pick it up and offer a full
refund so check it out
to personalize your sleep experience
visit helix sleep comm forward slash Tim
and you can get $50 off of your custom
mattress check it out helix sleep comm
forward slash temp this episode is
brought to you by Legal Zoom I've used
Legal Zoom for many of my businesses and
Matt Mullenweg as one example he's been
on the podcast CEO of automatic now
worth more than a billion dollars first
incorporated his company we're on Legal
Zoom when you run your own business you
know that time equals money so why waste
your valuable time dealing with issues
that LegalZoom can solve for you more
than 2 million people have used Legal
Zoom to start their businesses but their
services don't end at the beginning
Legal Zoom has the network of
independent attorneys licensed in all 50
states they can provide all the advice
you need nuts and bolts start to finish
and you don't need to worry about
billable hours because Legal Zoom isn't
a law firm that way you have upfront
pricing and complete clarity Legal Zoom
is a reliable resource that more than a
million people have already trusted to
help them with their businesses in all
sorts of different ways and that
includes setting up wills doing a proper
trademark search forming an LLC setting
up a non-profit or finding simple cease
and desist letter templates so check
them out
legalzoom.com take a look today to see
how they can make your life better
easier faster and more effective enter
promo code Tim T I am at checkout to
save 15% that's legalzoom.com and code
Tim for 15% off